now when you say skateboarding is more
nuanced than other sports uh could you
explain that a little bit more well I
think it's more that you can't wholly
categorize it as a sport yeah it's very
much a lifestyle a culture right an art
fan art yeah but there is that element
yeah that is highly competitive yeah
it's in the Olympics now right I mean
there are there are Superstar
competitors yeah but there are also
people who are wildly successful that
just skate that that show what they do
produce content and you know in other
forums social media or whatever else
um who are are revered in our world but
they're not competing they just love it
for what it provides them how what do
you think the percentage in you is
between you know show person and
competitor and has it and has it changed
over the years um yeah I'd say it's I
don't know that's a trick that's a good
question I think more that
when I started skating the only way you
could make any sort of success or have
any success was to compete yeah there
were no other alternative ways to be
known or to be recognized or to to have
support which would be like YouTube
channel exactly things like that yeah um
or or magazine coverage but the
magazines were only covering you if you
were doing well in competition okay they
only wanted to show your photo if you
got top three
and then maybe interview afterwards but
it was just more like that was the path
to having any sort of success or name
for yourself so I was born
in competition so I did it for 20 almost
30 years yeah and then
through those times I was doing a lot of
other things like exhibitions and tours
and we would go on the road and yeah and
then I I started to embrace that a lot
more and then when I finally made my
formal exit from competition I leaned
into
exhibition skating and doing doing
demonstrations and um so I guess that's
where my focus is more now but honestly
in recent years it's just been more
personal it's been more like I want to
keep progressing as much as I can at my
age yeah and I will document that along
the way yeah but I'm not gunning to get
out on the road anymore what effect has
had as age had on you I know there there
was like a pretty serious injury I broke
my femur a year ago and then you kind of
got back too fast I got back too fast
and my bone never connected back to
itself so I was and that's a big one too
yeah that's a big bone to not have
connect I literally didn't have a leg to
stand on
but I was in denial for almost seven
months maybe eight months of that it's
just gonna it's gonna reconnect it's
gonna happen and so I just kept I kept
skating I kept doing stuff in great pain
and then at some point got x-rays and
realized that it had moved further away
from itself Jesus over the over the
course of like actually like further
from each other laterally yeah just
laterally oh wow yeah they were it was
on top of each other then it moved
sideways and then it just kept moving
sideways wow and then I started to get
this sort of bow-legged limp going and
then and you were walking around I was
walking around but it but I just like I
said I was in denial I was limping
around and then uh finally went to a
specialist and he said oh this is what
they call a non-union fracture it's not
going to reconnect unless we actually
physically reset it put new Hardware in
and he had a master he had a plan of
action that was seems so matter of fact
yeah that I I had surgery the next week
oh wow and I have been on the right path
to recovery ever since right now I'm
back on my skateboard I'm skating
normally I'm walking normally was that
did you have like one of those Halos one
of those things with pins no no it was
all interior it's all interior yeah so I
have a big uh what they call a nail I
have a big nail yeah through both of my
wow pieces but now it's I have one bone
finally yeah success it was that ego was
that ego that kept you from
um yeah I think if you ask my wife yes
absolutely uh or or
uh stubbornness Obsession yeah but also
I had I think what it was that
I had a few events scheduled
that were in the foreseeable future and
I kept thinking I'm gonna get to that
event I'm gonna I'm gonna be in skating
mode by then yeah which was unrealistic
right but I kind of heard what I wanted
to hear from the experts
they said oh well six weeks you're bone
will be healed six weeks that's it six
weeks I'm back you know my bonus biggest
bone in my body this six weeks is just
not realistic yeah yeah and it wasn't it
was it was it partly that you didn't
want to let the people down or these
bookings that you had made was that part
of it or was it more just um that was
part of it but also I I thought I had
something to prove that I could just get
back at you know that I'm gonna defy
yeah my age I'm gonna defy expectations
and I'm gonna do it and and it was my
mistake I accept it and I'm just so
thankful to live in this age of modern
medicine yeah I had a second chance
right